Netflix is dropping more than a few exciting
new releases this November.
The final season of House of Cards is making
its debut this month, along with the Chris
Pine-led The Outlaw King.
And that's just the tip of the iceberg.
Here's everything good coming to Netflix in
November 2018.
Even though Kevin Spacey's out of the picture,
his character, Frank Underwood, will apparently
still play into the events of the final season
of House of Cards.
According to Reuters, the exact cause of his
death will be something of a lingering mystery
that's sticking around to haunt his widow
and the new president, Claire Underwood.
Check it out when House of Cards returns on
November 2nd.
Journey back to the clashing cultures of 1970
with ReMastered: Tricky Dick & The Man in
Black, a documentary about that time Johnny
Cash went to the White House to hang out with
Richard Nixon.
This is the second installment in Netflix's
musical documentary series, the first of which,
ReMastered: Who Shot the Sheriff, delved into
the 1976 assassination attempt on Bob Marley.
Look for Tricky Dick & The Man in Black on
November 2nd.
Only in 2018 would the epic unfinished film
by legendary director Orson Welles go straight
to streaming.
But here we are, on the cusp of the Netflix
release of a film over 40 years in the making.
Welles supposedly left behind ten hours of
raw footage for his satirical mockumentary,
and it's now been painstakingly edited together
into a finished product.
The Other Side of the Wind premieres on November
2nd, side-by-side with They'll Love Me When
I'm Dead, a documentary that explores the
making of the film.
In this one-man show, John Leguizamo delivers
a comedy filled stage drama that traces Latin
history from the Mayans to the modern day.
The show garnered Leguizamo a Tony nomination
for best play, and Netflix brought their cameras
to capture one of the acclaimed performances
in June 2018.
Tune in to John Leguizamo's Latin History
for Morons on November 5th.
Chris Pine stars in this upcoming Netflix
film as Robert the Bruce, the real-life historical
figure who organized the Scottish clans to
go to war against England.
From the looks of the trailers so far, Outlaw
King will be a bloody romp through history
that tracks Robert's path from fugitive to
King of Scots.
Take a look on November 9th.
Halloween certainly doesn't mark the end of
the year's horror releases, as Netflix's upcoming
May The Devil Take You proves.
The Indonesian fright flick focuses on a young
woman who travels to her father's old house
after he falls into a coma.
There, she discovers that dear old dad had
more than a few skeletons in his closet — and
some of them want to kill her.
Get ready for a dark descent into hell when
May The Devil Take You hits Netflix on November
15th.
You probably won't recognize Madeline Brewer's
name, but her face may ring a bell.
The young actress appeared in Orange is the
New Black, The Handmaid's Tale, and Black
Mirror, and now she's set to star in Netflix's
newest psychological thriller, Cam.
The film follows Alice, a webcam girl whose
life is hijacked by someone who looks just
like her.
That kicks off a harrowing mystery as Alice
tries to figure out what her doppelganger
wants from her.
Check it out on November 16th.
The Narcos spin-off Narcos: Mexico puts a
new cast of characters at the start of the
Mexican drug war, setting the series in the
early '80s and chronicling the bloody beginnings
of a violent cartel.
Michael Pena and Diego Luna are set to star,
and the new take on the series looks like
it'll be downright brutal but also pretty
amazing.
Dig in on November 16.
There's been a lot of hype building for The
Ballad of Buster Scruggs, the newest release
from Joel and Ethan Coen.
The anthology film twines together six different
stories about the American West, each infused
with the kind of dark comedy that could only
come from the Coen brothers.
Buster Scruggs has already hit the 2018 festival
circuit, and critics are loving it.
Will the rest of the world fall in love too?
Find out when it rides onto Netflix on November
16th.
Among all the historical shows on Netflix,
The Last Kingdom tends to fall between the
cracks.
That's a shame, because this period epic is
definitely worth the time to watch.
Originally created by BBC, The Last Kingdom
follows a warrior in the 9th century during
a time when what is now England was being
overrun by the invading Danes.
Between its high production values, solid
storytelling, and breathtaking battles, The
Last Kingdom is definitely worth checking
out.
Season 3 hits Netflix on November 19th.
Not to be confused with that other show about
the Archie comics character, this Sabrina
is a horror film about a doll that comes to
life after a little girl tries to bring her
mother back from the dead.
That's a cheerful premise, and the trailer
for Sabrina suggests that it only gets worse
from there.
Look for it to hit Netflix on November 20th.
The 2017 return of Mystery Science Theater
3000 gave fans plenty to love.
All the charm of the old series was back,
along with a brand new set of terrible films
to make fun of.
What's not to like?
With the next season, Jonah and his robo-friends
will be riffing on six new movies.
Grab your popcorn and settle in for the new
season on November 22nd.
Between The Last Kingdom and Frontier, Netflix
is bringing plenty of historical action to
the small screen in November.
Frontier is set in the Canadian frontier and
follows an outlaw who's dead set on wreaking
havoc on the region's fur trade.
That outlaw is Declan Harp, played by Jason
Momoa.
Whether you're a longtime fan or just now
getting into Frontier, you can look forward
to Season 3 when it arrives on November 23rd.
Netflix has two new standup specials slated
for November, and each one is well worth a
watch.
On the 20th, watch out for Trevor Noah: Son
of Patricia, which sees The Daily Show host
on-stage for an evening of hard-hitting jokes.
Then, November 27th heralds the arrival of
a double dose of comedy, when Jeff Ross and
Dave Attell both take the stage and take turns
roasting each other in a special called Bumping
Mics with Jeff Ross & Dave Attell.
That's all of the good Netflix originals coming
in November.
Now let's highlight a few of the best films
hitting the streaming service.
Alfonso Cuaron's excellent Children of Men
is the highlight of November's action additions,
arriving on the first.
The dystopian drama follows a disillusioned
alcoholic who's roped into protecting the
last known pregnant woman on Earth.
Cuaron used extensive long takes while filming,
leading to some pretty jaw-dropping action
scenes.
After that, look for Pirates of the Caribbean:
At World's End to sail onto streaming on November
4th.
There's also a flood of irreverent comedies
splashing onto Netflix on the first.
Look for Deuce Bigalow: European Gigolo, National
Lampoon's Animal House, and Scary Movie 2
and 3.
It might not be a high-brow selection, but
it's bound to be high-larious.
I can’t believe I just said that, Haha.
On the thriller side, Netflix is doubling
down on its post-Halloween chills.
On the first, keep your eyes open for Cloverfield,
From Dusk Till Dawn, Bram Stoker's Dracula,
and Transcendence.
On the 12th, Netflix is checking in Green
Room, an intense little movie about a band
stuck in a gig full of murderous neo-Nazis.
Anton Yelchin stars, with a sinister performance
by Patrick Stewart as the villain.